I won't even wish for snow but really I
do wish for a snow put up GQ I'm Mariah
Carey and these are my essentials
Christmas edition my first essential is
some time off for Christmas to be with
friends and loved ones I'm not working
I'm not on camera I don't have to think
about anything other than just existing
and giving love and receiving love and
enjoying the holiday spirit I like to be
in a snowy environment I've been going
to Aspen for a really long time even if
I'm just looking at the mountains it's
just a beautiful Christmas we do a lot
of fun things sleigh riding after dark
going through the snow looking at the
stars sing shooting stars
I have reindeer live reindeer that come
Santa Claus visits us each year we hang
out with Santa Claus I could go on and
on and on and on but I want to save some
of that for us
[Music]
I always see Santa Claus Santa Claus is
there we talk things over you might
think I'm making this up this is true
you know I'm kind of like the hotline
for Santa Claus so if anybody wants to
talk to Santa just like DME and we'll
we'll make it work I don't know about
friends but he comes and helps them
figure out what they need to do to be
better for the next year I like to cook
every year I cook on the 23rd or 24th
and 25th all different menus one of them
is one of my father's recipes before he
passed away he left me this recipe that
I like to make every year on Christmas
Eve then on Christmas we do a
traditional meal and I like it took me a
while to learn how to do the turkey I
didn't know what you're doing to make a
turkey you can't poison people I'm not
gonna lie I typically have a sous chef
there but I do have a very specific menu
that I won't go into right now because
one day I'm gonna put out a Christmas
cookbook a Christmas cookbook and a lot
of other things that are just kind of
like essentials for me
I used to bake a lot and one of my
favorite things to bake was German
chocolate cake and I wish I could find
it again I want to do that with my
daughter because she loves baking and
cooking you gotta cook with love if you
don't cook with love it's not gonna
taste good
love darling love people don't believe
that I cook by the way they think I'm
lying like lots of people like you don't
cook but the truth is is that I do and I
actually love cooking and I don't
usually cook during the year until
Christmastime but I've been cooking a
little bit more recently cuz my kids
like kind of like it when I cook and
even though it takes up a lot of time
it's it's relaxing for me because I'm
not thinking about business I'm not
thinking about anything else I'm just
down there in the kitchen cooking they'd
be surprised if they came over for
dinner diamonds even a ruby occasionally
I would say for most of the year
diamonds rule but at Christmas I do a
ruby thing and that's also kind of
seasonal that's important if somebody
turns off the Christmas music I get
really upset like if I wake up when
there's no Christmas music in the house
I freak out so it has to happen from the
time I am off for Christmas till like at
least the very least the 28th I have a
Christmas playlist that I've had for
several years that every year we listen
to and it's just like the most classic
Christmas songs to some of the most
obscure maybe some of the more obscure
James Brown Christmas cuts that people
don't know some people don't know Santa
Claus go straight to the ghetto but
that's one of my favorites and let's
make this Christmas mean something this
year that's another one well sometimes I
leave the album on too long and I'm like
this is a lot but I love those two songs
and I'm okay watching Christmas movies
there's so many great Miracle on 34th
Street it's a wonderful life for
Christmases it's a modern-day classic I
love elf
you know the Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer and all those little claymation
ones I love those Frosty the Snowman I
watched them all I'm literally like a
little kid at Christmas probably more
like a little kid than the kids I'm
around like worse than my own kids I
think Christmas feelings that come from
things that are from our childhood are
just always gonna be there whether it's
the claymation characters or different
cartoons that we've grown up watching
there's a nostalgia that you just can't
put your finger on but it's real and
it's tangible and it's truthful and this
is what brings me in and draws me in and
makes me feel just a pure love of the
holiday season I would love for my
family to always feel that closeness
that people feel when they truly love
each other and I think that the holiday
season it's heightened and sometimes
people get sad and sometimes people get
angry really easily and for me it's like
you've got to throw all that stuff aside
and do your best
to really just come together I'm just
thankful that I've been blessed with
that feeling because I don't get that
most of the year this is why Christmas
is so important to me and anybody
involved in my life will always
understand that this has to happen and
this is a moment that if I don't have
that the rest of the year doesn't even
matter
thanks GQ those are my Christmas
essentials
[Music]